we're here with eric kim author of his
debut cookbook korean american and eric
is bringing back the nostalgic tv dinner
with a modern twist i mean i love this i
talk about tv dinners all the time i
feel like we need to modernize them what
was your like point of view you know i
really think that a tv dinner is about
the comforting flavors that you remember
from your childhood you know this one's
just a little more homemade but the
potatoes they get kind of like crispy at
the edges oh yeah they do that and you
do you have like a little medley yeah so
i love that those are also garnished
which we didn't have on this one but
we're gonna garnish right now sesame
seeds with a little sesame seed um good
way to portion control too yeah that's
true we have two best friends in the
audience uh whitney and tim yeah um
where are you hi guys
hi
and
we like communal eating here so will you
guys taste this along with us oh
absolutely yes
how long have you guys been friends
three
three years old
yeah oh my god what did you eat first
you like it i'm so happy for you
i'm so happy
to be new friends with you eric this
is the most beautiful sauce
it's so sweet and tangy tangy and sweet
and like savory oh my god
sauce is amazing if you like really use
it i like overdoing flavors
i balance each other out fine potato
sauce even though this is on the warmer
side cooling to the palette after
something so zesty exactly whitney and
tim thoughts quickly before we end the
show uh amazing so good delicious the
spirit the ribs are so good the sauce is
just oh it's incredible i'm so very
happy
oh my god well thank you so much for
eating with us and
eric kim your beautiful new cookbook
korean american food that tastes like
home which really is about home it's you
know a love letter to your mother and i
think this is a show about writing love
letters and book forms to our family
so thank you so much this is sold
wherever books are sold get your hot
little hands on this beautiful book
[Music]